All right, so please give me a hand in
welcoming to the stage. Jim letterer.
Hi,
I am Jen letterer and you are a unicorn.
Now,
what just went through your mind when
you heard me say that when you heard I am
a Unicorn,
were you closer to the side of yes,
I am a unicorn.
Thank you for finally recognizing me or
were you to the side of like at best,
at best, you're skeptical. Now
other Unicorns in the room,
those of you who are
like totally embodying,
already knowing welcome,
really excited to have you.
But the others,
the skeptic,
the ones who question what in the world
I could possibly be getting at with
that, the ones who may be rolled their
eyes a little bit when you heard it,
even if it was an internal role,
you are the ones that I'm really excited
to be with today because I have learned
that one of the fastest ways to grow is
by learning to ask the right questions
by having a critical mind and
by embracing that skeptic.
And it kind of likes to talk a lot
of games in the back of your mind.
So
don't shy away from the questions that
might come up today because everything
I'm here to share with you was
actually born out of my own skepticism,
my own questions and doubts about what
is being taught in regards to leadership.
There's all of these buzz
words around leadership, right?
Oh,
and your power be vulnerable.
Lean in, right? Just, Oh, your shadow.
And here's the thing. I
agree with all of it. Okay.
I think it's great authenticity rock.
But the way I see it being talked
about can a lot of times lead to
misunderstanding,
pressure to be a certain way,
which when you're thinking about being
authentic just seems ridiculous and it
can lead to pain.
Okay.
So here's an example of a scenario,
a conversation that I have
seen play out multiple times.
So someone says,
Hey,
I'm really ready to step into my power
and own my greatness and be a leader.
Where do I start?
Okay.
So all you have to do is be authentic.
Like really just like be yourself.
Okay.
Um, okay, got that. Really
appreciating that. Thank you so much.
But a quick followup question.
What do you mean?
Okay.
So like you just need to be your yourself.
Oh.
And your vulnerabilities puts
your shadows into the world.
Really show people that you have
overcome all of your battles and you are
stronger.
Okay.
Um, again, really
appreciating that advice.
One last followup question. No. Um,
if let's say I'm not a hundred percent
confident with what I have to say,
or I'm actually not even sure
I'm worthy of being a leader.
And then I don't even know what to say.
Like what Ben.
Oh, it sounds like you just need to
believe in yourself a little more.
Like have you tried positive affirmation?
Because I feel like once I really
started to believe in myself,
it was all good from there.
No, again, so much for that. Amazing. Um,
the mice and then you're left with,
okay,
I got it.
The key to my success lies within.
Yeah,
but there's all this talk
about what you have to do,
the authentic be vulnerable,
but there's not a lot of talk about how
you are suppose to get there and what it
is really supposed to look like for you.
So much pressure on that
vulnerability piece. Right.
And I see this trip people up a lot.
They will say things like,
Jen, okay, so I have a story,
but I'm not really sure I'm
ready to share it with the world.
And is that honestly the only
way I can make a difference,
I have to expose my deepest,
darkest secrets to the
world can make a difference.
And then there's people who say
live the kind of blessed life.
I don't have this big terrible
thing that happened to me.
So does that mean that I'm
not as effective as a leader,
as someone who has been
through hell to get here?
And then there's this really weird message
about trying to be grateful for the
things that have happened,
right?
Trying to love the difficult
challenges in your life.
Now it may sound like I'm mocking some
of that advice because I am kind of
again,
all of that has a place.
You guys all have a positive effect.
Amazing laying in front of you right now,
you are limitless.
I believe in the power of a lot of this,
but only when it's used correctly.
Not from this place of pressuring yourself
to stretch out pride of your comfort
zone farther than you're ready for or
risk the safety of yourself in honor of
leadership.
So what is it not about the thing,
the story.
What if it's not about what
you're putting out into the world?
And it's more about how you are showing
up in the world being not doing.
Yeah.
So do you help me kind of explain this
journey of coming to conscious leadership
and how you can get there.
I brought some friends,
I brought some friends along with me and
these friends include a unicorn if you
didn't see it coming,
this Unicorn represents you and me,
but you as well.
So we have a unicorn.
We also have trolled off little
throwback sound maybe. Oh,
I know this guy represents your fear,
your self sabotage,
your ego,
all of the noise that gets in the way
right before you go and try and do
something great as this guy.
Okay.
And our stomping grounds for this journey.
Our belt out of rose quartz.
Okay.
So the first rose court is intuition.
The second row sport. I feel like
Vanna white at the moment. Excuse me,
let me step to the other side. Um,
the second round, sports and safety,
that's third.
Authenticity and the four impact.
Now, if it's not about, the thing
is, it's not about your story.
If it's not about clinging to a specific
identity of something that happened or
something you experienced or
something you feel that you are.
If it's not about that,
then what are we looking for
and what we're here to look for
and explore today is the lesson,
the lesson you learned because
of the thing that happened.
And if you're someone in here who has
lived a really blessed life and you're
like, oh you trust me, you picked
up some lessons along the way.
Living in this world,
the lessons that turn into pattern that
turn into beliefs that turned into a
false truth,
right?
You picked up and embody and
Harry with you every day.
Okay?
Your story is not with us today,
but your pattern,
your beliefs,
the things you feel are
true about yourself.
Those are with us right now.
That's where I want to beat big
believer of the power of present moment.
So that's where we're going to say the
things that are with you right now are
the most powerful tool.
Tell learning about yourself.
So you have to understand we're
coming in mid scene here, okay?
We're like turning on the TV mid scene
back in the day when you actually turned
on TV and didn't just pick
what you wanted to watch. Um,
and the Unicorn just had a thing happen,
right?
Something just happened and she's having
a conversation with her fear and it
sounds something like
this. Oh my God, Oh my God,
something just happened and I need to
make sure that that thing never happens
again. Oh my God. And fear
is sitting there saying,
I told you not to do that.
I told you not to be so noticeable.
I told you this day under the radar,
what have we learned today?
What have we learned today?
Okay?
And the Unicorn says,
well,
I learned it's not safe to be seen.
Okay?
And I'm not lovable.
Okay.
Now these are the Unicorns,
false truths that she picked up.
You may have your own,
you may be starting to kind
of realize what yours are,
or maybe not. That's okay,
but you're out this journey.
Just see if you can tune
into what are my truth.
That's a question that I would
love for you to dance with.
So as a Unicorn realizes it is
not safe to be seen as a unicorn.
I still have things I want to say.
I still have things I want to do.
Just because it's not safe to be seen
doesn't mean I have to quit all together.
So she tells fear. First of all,
you stay in the dark, right?
This is what everyone tells us about fear,
what it in the jar.
Don't worry about it. Don't
look at it. Be Fearless, right?
So let's see how this works out for her.
We're going to put him back in the dark,
not to be heard from because she said,
I'm going to be fearless and I'm going to
go out into the world as a white horse.
Now,
why horses are still powerful creatures.
They can get a lot done in the world.
So she didn't lose all her seem
right. She just realized, okay,
this is what it is.
This is the card I've been dealt.
Okay.
So she moves into her first
rose quartz intuition.
She gets quiet
and she hears it's not safe to be seen.
You are not lovable.
Now.
You have to understand that
from here on out in her journey,
her entire being,
her entire intention is always
about keeping her and her truth.
St
Okay?
No one is going to make her bud.
No one is going to convince her
otherwise because she has learned.
She has experienced
that this is her truth,
but she still has things to say,
so she presses on leaving her intuition
behind because as far as she's
concerned, the lesson has been
learned. It's not going to change,
so still just keep it as is
and know that that's the truth,
okay?
Now,
in the land of safety,
this is where you start to gain the
tools that help support your truth.
So in this land,
this is where you might start
looking for other white horses,
other people who are
playing under the radar,
not rocking the boat too much.
You start to become very paternal with
looking at what other people are doing,
being incredibly aware of the competition,
because listen,
if the internal conversation
is you're not lovable,
okay,
the external goal is I have
to at least be likable.
I have to at least be likable.
Look at me.
So there are a lot of,
there's a lot of pressure to get people
on board with who you are to validate
your truth, to validate this
new life as a white horse.
Cause you got things to say and
nothing's going to stop you.
Okay.
Now in my world,
in this space,
I was solid with my white hoarseness.
No one by this point could tell me I was
a uniform and I had just moved to New
York fresh out of college
here to be a dancer.
Now you can imagine that the cocktail of
not being lovable and it's not safe to
be seen,
there's a killer doc Dale to be bringing
into the entertainment industry. Right?
So I would go to auditions
and I mean hate it.
I would have to take the rest of the day
off just to bounce back from the damn
experience.
And then I will get callbacks and not go.
I would not go to dance class
for like months at a time,
but still tell people I was a dancer
and I didn't realize it at the time.
But all of those patterns
were me supporting my truth,
being myself safe because I had
learned it's not safe to be seen.
I'm not lovable, so I'm going
to go almost, but not quite.
I'm going to go as far as it is the
unsafe and then I'm going to pull back
because it's called survival.
Moving a little bit farther.
I accepted that.
Okay.
The dance thing is not going to be where
I'm at because I don't show up for it.
So I started singing.
I co wrote an off off Broadway show.
I co wrote an album. They did great.
The performances were awesome.
The songs are amazing,
but I did not do one performance sober.
I was at least three drinks lubricated
by the time I stepped on stage.
Okay.
Not because I so badly wanted to embody
the rock star lifestyle and be drunk on
stage. I really didn't even
realize what I was doing.
And again,
I was fighting for my truth saying I am
a white horse and it might not be safe
to be seen,
but I'm going to do as much as I can
in the limits that are in my life.
So I danced with that
for a while with almost,
but not quite.
And then as I moved into being authentic,
now you guys,
you have to realize I was
being as authentic as I knew
I could be by this point.
The fact that I was a unicorn was
like a deep buried memory at best.
Again, if I even had the memory
of it now, by this point,
I had gotten the opportunity to
run a talent management company.
Now this was like, oh, I found
it. I found my sweet spot.
I can help people get into the spotlight,
but I can be an arm's length
distance from it and feel sick.
And I was good at this job.
There was negotiating,
there was power.
I was a decision maker.
I was working with really
high powered producers.
I was moving a rube and things were good,
so I Yay because why not?
I finally found a nice balance
where I can work with artists.
I could be involved in that world,
but I could also stay in the shadows,
make an impact,
be authentic.
And Stacy.
Yeah,
because I was fighting for this.
True.
You have to understand that everybody
is doing the best they can at all times.
It may not seem that way,
but everybody is fighting for their truth.
Okay.
So as I moved into impact,
the company was doing great.
Actors were booking really amazing thing.
I was getting compliments some
producers who were watching me,
how I ran my company saying,
you're doing a great job and keep going.
Just as I felt like I
was hitting my stride,
I was winning all the races.
Right? I was the best white horse,
just the one I got comfortable with that.
Okay.
The whispers started coming in.
And the whisper asked me,
okay,
but all of these actors to be seen.
Okay.
Might it be safe for you to,
Nah, ignore that. Right?
Because why would I risk everything
I built all of my success,
all of the people who were counting
on me to continue on this path.
Why would I risk follow a whisper?
No, not going to happen, and that is why
I so fiercely believe that you cannot
just convince yourself into a new reality.
You cannot just start with the blows
and think that it's actually going to
change what you believe to be true.
You cannot go to a single mom of two
kids who is up at 1:00 AM at her kitchen
table crying because
in an eviction notice,
you can't go to her and say
what?
She doesn't want to believe that you
think she doesn't want so badly to
experience this abundance that
everyone is talking about.
She wants to,
but she's fighting for a truth.
Okay,
a true,
that probably sounds something
like every nickel you earn,
you've got a bleed for it and
you're not even worthy of much.
If that is your embodied
truth and someone says to you,
the universe is abundant,
they might as well be looking
at you and saying your Unicorn
there is,
it doesn't resonate because of everything
she has experienced in her life thus
far has proven otherwise.
Yeah.
No,
it's not about convincing yourself.
What is it?
What is it that gets
you to switch and say,
oh my gosh,
that might be possible for me.
Yeah.
So in my world,
the whole,
maybe it they've been like that
with her was not working on me.
Like the universe was
like, okay, she's stubborn.
She's not going to react to this one.
We got to go at it from another angle.
Universities persistent.
So it went after my other belief.
You are not lovable.
Okay.
And at the time I was dating someone who
revealed themselves to be a narcissist.
Yeah.
And it got to point where I had to
stop painting the red flags white.
I had to look at what was
really happening here,
the lying, the cheating, the
manipulation, the emotional abuse.
And I had to look at it and say,
this really all I'm worth.
Okay.
And the whisper came in
and asked,
what if you are lovable?
The questions,
the questions that get you to wonder what?
Yeah.
Okay.
Not the demand to believe that it is true.
Me. Ooh. The Taishan to ask what?
Yeah.
Why is the place where you can
begin to have somebody release?
They're true and that is
oh really brave thing to do
because you don't know what's
waiting for you on the other side.
In hindsight, you look
back and you're like, oh,
that's why I had to let go because
that was coming in and it's all real
beautiful from the backend.
But when you're living it and someone
asks you to let go of the truth that you
have been living for
possibly multiple decades,
it's going to take a law
or it's going to take one moment
where all of a sudden you realize,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
The thing I thought was
true might not be true.
And with that in my world when I
realized, Oh, maybe I am lovable,
then the maybe it's safe
to be seen came with it.
So I had it back to the
beginning where I came from,
cause I had somebody to talk to. I knew
that was going to happen. All right. Who?
She went back and talk to
fear because he was like, Hey,
remember how we said it wasn't
safe for me to be seen? Well,
I'm starting to doubt that.
And you had all this crazy
stuff to say and fear is like,
I'm so glad you came back.
I've been trying to get your attention.
You were out there trying to be fearless.
I'm back.
You're trying to get your attention
because I'm not your enemy.
And he said, by the way, you
know that you're a unicorn.
Yeah.
And she's like, what? This
whole time I'm out there,
you saw me. I'm out there.
I'm like, no. Fear was like,
can I come with you now this time? Can
we do what it done? And she's like,
well I'm a uniform.
I did all that on the white horse.
How'd you what I can do with a Unicorn
now the fear says I'm coming with you.
Let me get, let me get my outfit now.
Yes, I'm going to put his outfit on.
I promise you it's worth the wait.
It's totally worth the payoff
because look, you guys,
if you were to hire somebody,
a private investigator to tell you
exactly what's going on with you,
who is your
really good news for everyone?
We all have one and he works pro bono.
So
this is now, hmm. We're starting
to build our squad goals,
right?
So off she goes as a unicorn
back at her intuition,
same thing.
She gets quiet.
The truth is it is safe to
be seen and you are lovable.
So just before
our re thing from here on out is about
protecting her and her truth by eating to
bill that true.
Now as you move the same thing,
she's learned lesson to bring your
intuition with you because those change
things can change along the way.
This isn't the only catalyst
that's going to happen in her life.
So she brings the intuition and of
course you get your man who has your back
ready to let you know if
anything weird is going on.
Okay?
Now this same thing you guys.
This is the really important place.
This is where the positive affirmations
can start to work because they are no
longer debating your truth.
They are supporting what you now
are already open to believing.
Okay?
This is where maybe you have to stop
hanging out with some of the white horses
that really used to fit
kind of who you were,
but now that you're a unicorn,
they're kind of intimidated by the
whole thing and it just gets weird. No,
you lose some people in this space.
It can be painful.
This is also the space where you do
want to explore those stories and those
things that happen,
those panelists in your life.
This is where you get to own your power
and you decide what gets shared with the
world.
What gets put out there,
because baring your soul does
not equal leadership and power.
Oh,
knowing your stuff so you can
become a mirror of what is possible,
not is what we're working on.
So I can't tell you what authentic
leadership looks like for you.
If that means bearing your soul
is telling the world your story,
go for it, right? It's all you.
Kim.
Kardashians means to strip down every
other week and get on social media to feel
empowered. Hey girl, do you?
But there is a not messaging out there
that is telling people you have to
overcome and prove that you're stronger
than I can take John All the judgment
because your fearless.
There's enough of that.
I'm here to give voice to the
person who says, you know what?
There's more to me than one
event that happened in my life.
Okay?
And this is where you get to start
exploring all of who you are.
And then when you move into authenticity,
remember we're bringing all of your tools.
You're not leaving these safety pools
that you just built behind because you
know you're going to
keep building as you go,
right? Asking for help,
working with a coach,
working with the therapist,
really out,
allowing yourself to be supported.
Not because you're weak,
but because you understand
that when I get this support,
it allows me to be more of who I am.
Okay?
So in this game by this space,
I started realizing that number one,
I want to infuse comedy into everything
that I do, so I'm going to do it.
Okay?
It's the kind of authenticity that when
you book one of the coolest speaking
gigs of your career and they're like,
hey Jen,
are you going to have slides in your life?
Know what?
I'm going to bring a stuffed Unicorn.
It's roll down, throw the card. Cool.
Awesome.
That's the kind of stuff that happens.
You're not looking around wondering
what other people are doing because it's
irrelevant to what you are working
on here and what you have to offer.
Okay,
so this final piece,
when she moves into impact
and she has her intuition,
her safety,
her real authenticity,
not the one that someone told her he's
supposed to have in order to be authentic.
This kind of self awareness.
Okay.
Is the conscious leadership
because you start to become a living,
breathing how to list for people.
Okay.
You're not running around
trying to save them.
Okay.
Because you know that the
catalyst is just the question,
how to list is that moment
that makes someone go, oh,
maybe what I thought was true isn't true.
As a leader,
if you can get people to feel
safe enough to release that.
True.
Did they have been calling
for dear life out of survival?
If you can get people to release that,
that is leadership.
Yeah.
The rest of their journey,
right?
They have to choose to go back to the
beginning and talk to their fear about
what the hell went down
and am I a unicorn?
And when did you choose to not
tell me I was Unicorn? Right?
Wow.
Is conscious leadership.
Okay.
Oh name.
When people say own your power,
step into the light might be seen.
When I hear people say,
be seen,
the first thing I ask is,
are you seeing yourself?
Okay?
So if you don't begin with
positive affirmations, right?
If it's not just a leap to
convince yourself of what it is,
then where do you begin?
You begin by looking for your truth.
What am I fighting for right now?
What do I believe so much that it's
true that I will deny everything else.
Someone could come in here
right now and tell me I,
I'm a Unicorn and until I feel
that I am until I feel that,
yeah, that's all. Yes.
Getting quiet,
having the courage to wonder what if
where so many people that say to me,
Jen,
I don't even think it's responsible
for me to dream in that way.
Right? It's just, it's just not
worth while. I've got a job there,
but got family up things like a things,
it's not responsible to dream.
Right? While it's a truth,
people hold on to a law.
I have to keep running my race.
I'm a white horse who wins all the races.
Don't tell me to slow down.
I'm surviving.
Okay.
And as a conscious leader,
you are the invitation
that it is safe
to start that exploration for yourself.
A good leader does not judge their success
by how many people they've been able
to convince.
Right?
Or how many people are
trying to now be like them.
A conscious leader looks
around at their world and says,
I'm here to help.
All of you be more of who you are.
Even if right now you're a white horse,
the best white horse you can be.
So when the question comes,
you hear it
and you're not afraid of it,
and you're willing to follow it.
So it's not about what you're
putting out into the world.
It's about how you show up.
Hi,
I'm Jen.
Let her and to you our Unicorn.
Thank you.